please welcome Tiffany look at all these
handsome ball players in the crowd yes
the Aussie I see for now y'all better
not shoot y'all shot at me because I'm
ovulating
and I will take advantage I got a safety
pin
[Applause]
give it up for Jeff Ross that is Dwayne
Wade get to start the show and then sit
in the crowd finally learned how to play
defense huh
all right you all know the legendary
story about Charles Barkley's first
sneaker deal he was 19 years old and he
said to a guy
give me those sneakers or I'll [ __ ]
kill you give it up for Gary Payton this
is the 30th anniversary for the inside
the NBA Artie's been stuck in the same
place for 30 years
Ernie they let Odie out nine you know
what I'm saying
you need a jet to Smith got his nickname
after a flight to Jacksonville
then all of a sudden it was saying sir
please you please can you take a seat
with your group next call you had to
take your seat with the net with you
it's your mess having a bad joke bad
joke give it up for Gary Payne one more
time y'all [ __ ] ain't easy ain't mm-hmm
just cuz you read books out loud the
kids don't mean you can read off a
teleprompter
[Applause]
you're just doing your regular community
service mile [ __ ] your next roaster is a
well-known youtuber so you can think all
your dumb at double-a sorry sorry I'm
I'm reading like Gary now here we go
yeah you know what [ __ ] that [ __ ] look I
learned how to read at 16 when you learn
how to read me I got nominated for a
Grammy for reading out loud for my audio
book what'd you get a Grammy for okay
let's be honest I didn't get the Grammy
but I got nominated now I might not be
the best cause it's white words moving
fast on a black screen had they put it
on a white screen with black words I
will be able to absorb that better I'm
reading racist
please welcome jb smooth
like Jay Pharoah is here funny as hell
man extremely versatile comedian
it was truly messed up when SNL lets you
go but I'm here to tell you man that
Michael Qi do being better than you
should have nothing to do with that [ __ ]
you keep it moving babe you keep it
moving no black man shows have a last
name I dare you goddamn way I care about
you say I really care about you a lot
man I'm in so sad at your hands I'm just
as bad as your goddamn feet they're
interchangeable you look at easily where
your hands and your feet and your feet
as your hands I'm gonna pay good money
and see you high five
yo damn foot with so hand I'll pay good
money to see that but a serious no don't
congratulations to Chuck I heard your
hometown of Leeds Alabama gave you the
the big honour a key to the city that's
the big [ __ ] right there the key to the
goddamn city that's big oh that's big
huge that's huge
this is too bad that leads the key to
the city is nothing but wire cutters and
a goddamn rock country's here Charles
give it up for the dude I have wet
dreams about often Jay Pharoah
[Applause]
[ __ ] hey hey Rick Fox I see you try to
have [ __ ] I see you it Rick Fox
later that all-star had me you look just
like animal [ __ ] Antonio Banderas I've
always wanted to tell you that [ __ ] I
got lost on my way here tonight when
they said we were doing this at the
House of Blues I went to Madison Square
Garden
sorry Knicks didn't know really y'all
sorry as hell you know hello sorry yes
Charles did a DNA test on TV that showed
he's 14 percent Native American just
what he needed another reason to spend
Thanksgiving eating like a depressed
person
I don't know we're slower man Shaq
speech patterns or reparations for
slavery you can laugh at that one Jeff
you racist [ __ ] irony
honey you look like the Cryptkeeper in
Joker's makeup is it just me or is
Charles getting a little crazy out there
they all right yeah that's right first
white dude and do the Joker walk a pig's
impression you like it [ __ ] you all
right let's go
I dug deep when I get up let me go back
I'm gonna get it again
I'll get it again doing a j.b smoove
impression
what's the hole okay
I know I know that's why I say this [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] we don't okay she ready so
before we leave we should all do a
tick-tock video don't worry just like
y'all it won't be hard and it'll only
take like a minute you like that I like
that yeah we love you good night jabu
jabu's blue team so big if he Tiffany
Haddish are they gonna do my
hysterectomy
[Applause]
hey hey and stop calling Gary P no stop
calling Gary Payton a glove all them
kids here never use a glove hey I just
want to say this about Ernie Johnson
before we wrap it out is it just me or
just Ernie Johnson look like Billy
Crystal's younger taller brother okay
it's just me that's just cuz I just work
with Billy Crystal that sounded I want
to get his big jokes
[Applause]
and it was Gary wrote it for me I was
like damn Gary okay i'ma try it and see
what happens
all right enjoy the rest of your routine
[Applause]